all right good morning
everybody well welcome to jail
car uh we have a number of alternates
that will be seated uh representative
groda for Senator Whitley representative
hackin Phillips for Senator
hatches
represent hope I can't got it right um
and Senator gray for Senator
inis so we have
take I
did did
you it doesn't much matter yes here we
are
um and Senator Ward will be joining us
shortly all right
to review the minutes is there a
motion all right second SEC
representative Gro a move to approve the
minutes seconded by
uh Senator uh Lang and there's Senator
Whitley all right
um in that case
um representative groa you're on
Deck any just any comments or
Corrections on the
minutes they've already it's already
been moved thank you uh those in
favor opposed uh Madam chair I believe
it was representative groa who initially
made the motion so if she's now on Deck
I think the motion has to be made again
again representative Schmidt has already
made it again so we're
covered okay uh we have a couple
[Music]
of um items to
postpone there's
um item
3D and um
3G the uh from you
services and they're both from HHS and U
Madam chair um just so you are aware on
item 3A
202312 the board has also asked for that
to be postponed so that they have time
to file a conditional approval and that
will need a jail car deadline as well as
um item waiver okay all right so we have
three items to postpone would someone
like to make a motion M chair I move
that we postpone all three items item 3A
being waved for terms and conditions as
well yes
representative okay second any
discussion
comments all right those in favor I
opposed all right the consent agenda are
Madam chair on the consent agenda item R
is has a late filed conditional approval
so the committee first needs to vote to
accept that late item and then they can
move to vote on the consent agenda the
um which which one is this item R oh the
from Employment Security yes ma'am okay
that has a
um a corrective action that is a
conditional approval request that was
late filed yes
ma'am all right so we we'll need a
waiver on that as well correct just need
to vote to approve the late filed item
first since the agency didn't file a uh
waiver of the the deadline to file and
then once you vote to approve that then
you can move to to approve the con
consent
agenda all right so
moved
second is there any dis discussion on
the employment security uh conditional
approval all right seeing none those in
favor I
opposed all right Adam J I move the
consent agenda as
amended
any discussion comments or anything else
to be
removed seeing none those in favor I
opposed thank you
all yes repr represent gr oh you're just
reminding about
that on the regular agenda the Board of
Medicine so these rules have to do with
the phys position assistant rules it is
the med
600s um an amended conditional approval
was filed um but there were still a
couple of questions that were remaining
uh one was that we still had not
received a copy of the initial
application form it is the universal
form that the oplc has been using um so
that wasn't so big of a problem but we
did receive an actual copy of it
yesterday but the other issue was that
their renewal form is on their portal so
I was not unable to see how it looked on
the portal as compared to the universal
renewal application looking at my inbox
it seems as though that was submitted
this morning but unfortunately I've not
had an opportunity to look at it quite
yet and in addition to that um there is
a note to jail car on page three of the
amended conditional approval
text that section had initially been in
the initial proposal
but then was taken out in the final
proposal however it being reinserted in
the amended conditional
approval pretty much verbatim for what
the statute says uh addressed my concern
that it had been removed in the first
place the next comment
um has to do with the fees on page four
of the amended conditional approval text
there's an unclear comment uh because
these rules are adopted
the PLC 10002 fees um which there is an
informational note that I won't get into
uh at this time but
additionally there is current effective
rules the med
[Music]
36.011677
so there's a conflict there but then
additionally I wanted to to bring to
your attention that currently the board
of medicine's website says that the
initial application fee is $23 so we
have three different fees um for the
initial proposal uh and just on that
note on page five there's the same issue
with the renewal fee um they're adopting
the PLC rules which list it as
$175 the med
36.016222
$3 um I'd like to hear from the agency
on that
issue thank you um Madam chair members
of the committee Lindsay Courtney
executive director Office Professional
Li Insurance
certification so um currently the fees
that were recently um approved by jail
car um related to the PLC 1002s
established the fee of I believe it's
$175 for Physicians um but the 101s
which were previously approved by jail
car establish a fee of $28 for the
professionals health program which is a
different fee um that we are required to
charge um it's a mandatory fee um
required by Statute um and so we've gone
back and forth about how to essentially
um communicate this fee to lenses
because there's uh been a lot of
confusion um as to what the total fee is
um and if we don't specifically list uh
if we in the past we have listed the
fees separately and then people will
send in 175 and then they don't pay the
28 and then we aren't able to issue the
license so the
203 is the12 fee plus the $28 PHP fee
which is in the 1,000
ones okay that explains two of them
what's the third fee um so they
currently effective um medicine rules
that list out a different fee so
that particular rule lists not only the
initial and renewal but all the other
fees which is what I assume it hasn't
been uh repealed on an expedited basis
yet but I will let the board confirm
whether my assumption is
correct yes correct I think the
committee is aware that there are
conflicts in rules regarding fees um we
have attempted to start the process of
cleaning that up but the first step of
that process was to adopt a universal
set of rules applicable establishing all
fees which was the
102s so as we move forward with Ru
making for each board we will be
cleaning that up hopefully with a
citation incorporating the PLC 10002s
but certainly as it stands right now
there are conflicts in rules there are
also conflicts in in statutes as it
relates to op's
Authority all
right representative Lon um thank you
madam chair um looking at the scope of
practice one that was added back in that
looks like that's rule 30601 which is
which is the one that currently is the
licensing fees um I'm curious that if we
adopt these rules does that mean that
the med 30601 fee schedule um will be
deleted from Rules I will have to relook
at the rule real quick but these should
be the med 600 rules not the 300s um
sorry not enough coffee this morning
that's okay um but just to confirm uh
that that's correct yes okay all right
and one problem solved and then the uh
last comment that I had on this
particular proposal is on page six of
the amended conditional approval text um
that particular rule has to do with um
supervision of physician assistance
saying that they will be supervised by a
participating physician however earlier
in the rules on Med 62.0
3D that gives a specific exemp uh
exception to supervision which is if the
participating physician either leaves
the practice or is uh unable to practice
due to illness they have 30 days so that
uh exception just has to be incorporated
in uh the
uh supervision rule that requires
supervision
okay Tina Kelly um office of
professional Li Insurance certification
and we their suggested rule um change
language for that which we will add
in okay thank
you any other questions
comments representative leam um thank
you madam chair if there is no
supervising physician with a physician's
assistant because of those do they need
to notify the patient that there's not a
supervising I'm just it's it I just
don't know if that's going a little
further a field so the statute silent on
that there is a statute that does allow
a physician assistant to practice for 30
days without supervision if those two
circumstances occur but it's silent on
whether or not the patient has to be
notified so and I'm unaware of if the
board has additional rules on
that Miss Kelly do you know if if there
are any additional rules on notifying
patients not that I know
of
okay I would just add for context that
there was a legislative change I believe
it was last session there used to be
required explicit supervision and they'd
have to register with the board their
supervisor there was a legislative
change that allows a PA to essentially
practice independently with a
collaborative practice agreement um but
there does not appear to be in statute a
requirement that the patient be
notified okay
questions Senator gray I moved to
approve with the
amendment okay any further
discussion seeing none those in favor
I those opposed all right and thank you
very much for the clear explanation of
the different rule different
fees Madam chair yes I'm sorry I didn't
mention at the outset but our
stenographer is absent today she's
hosting her son's wedding
um so she will be doing the uh
transcript from the video and from uh
the minutes that we create so it would
be very important for everyone to speak
into the microphone so she can hear the
video ah thank you for the for the uh
comment all
right P's Development
Authority um so these have to do with
the um PDA 600 rules um state-owned
commercial peers and Associated
facilities the uh agency did submit a
conditional approval that addressed
quite a majority of the comments however
there were still some small
discrepancies between the rule text and
some of the forms there were a number of
forms that were submitted with this
particular proposal uh so I have talked
with the agency they have agreed um to
make changes in order to address those
discrepancies so if it is all right with
the committee I would like to go through
each of the discrepancies and then just
give a potential recommendation for a
change and if the committee and the
agency agree on that then the committee
can um vote to approve this rule based
on the conditional approval filed and
then based on the Amendments talked
about in the oral
testimony
okay so to start on page four of the
condition additional approval text um
having to do with the annual peer use
application and permit at the bottom of
the page the form asks for peer use
location and whether a skiff permit is
required um OS is suggesting that these
requirements be added into that uh
section in the rule
text the next one is on page five of the
conditional approval text regarding the
single use peer permit application form
the form asks also for the peer
location um and whether or not the
applicant wants to use their mailing
address or permanent address um as a
means for receiving Communications but
that's not in the rule text so OS is
recommending that these two requirements
also be added into the rule text to
address that
issue also on page five um regarding the
annual birthing permit application and
permit form the rule text asks for a
business fax if the applicant has one
but there is nowhere on the form where
this is required um as the additional uh
the previous forms don't have this
requirement OS would recommend that they
just delete this requirement from the
rule text um additionally for that same
form there's a minor minor discrepancy
between the rule text uh certification
language and the certification language
on the form the form in one place says
my placement but the rule text just says
placement so Os Os would suggest that my
be inserted into the rule text before
placement in that
section just two more on the bottom of
page five regarding the daily seasonal
parking application and permit the form
asks if the applicant is applying for a
seasonal overnight in the parking for
Section um this is not a requirement in
the rule text and additionally there is
also another form that is specific for
seasonal overnight parking so it's
unclear why this requirement is on the
daily seasonal parking application form
as well um in order to address that OS
would recommend that that uh selection
the seasonal overnight just be deleted
from the form so it's
clear uh that there are different forms
and also it's consistent with the rule
text and the final comment is at the
bottom of page six regarding the
seasonal overnight parking application
and permit the rule text is still asking
for the applicant to include the season
for which the seasonal overnight parking
is sought however the form doesn't have
a place to indicate that instead it only
says that the season shall be from April
1st through November 15th which is found
under the fee section on the
form um based on that OS assumed that
there was only one season for which can
be applied for this particular
particular permit so OS would recommend
that the rule text be amended so that
that requirement is
deleted um and that is all that I had
for this particular
proposal
okay good good morning for the record
Gan Omar conone I'm the director at the
peas Development Authority division of
ports and harbers and uh we been working
with the office on making these
Corrections um they have a better eye
for it than we do so we have no
objections to any of these Madam
chair thank you that's good to know are
there any questions or comments from the
committee go ahead move to approve with
the edits OS
requested all
right that wasn't I I heard senat
representative Schmidt first but I could
be wrong was oh representative ly sorry
was off out way oh okay is there any
further
discussion seeing none those in favor I
opposed all right and thank you for your
efforts thank you very
much okay we postpone the radio
nucleid all right Health and Human
Services um so this has to do with
family centered early supports and
services the hm hm 510 rules um a
conditional approval was filed with the
division uh excuse me with the ol but uh
there was one additional comment
um that needed to be addressed um
for excuse me there are two comments
that need to be addressed but one the
department filed proposed language with
us yesterday a copy of which I have
placed at each of your seats so you can
take a look um having to do with hem
51014 they have inserted uh new
paragraphs G and H uh which addressed my
initial comment on the conditional
approval text um and therefore I have no
further comment on that particular issue
uh so the only remaining issue I had was
on page 37 of the conditional approval
text with regard to the waiver form in
the rule text it says that the era
agency the F cess program parent or a
provider May request a waiver of a
specific procedure in this rule chapter
however when you look at the waiver form
at the very top uh it's next to the
second Aster asteris it says that
waivers shall be submitted by the area
agency only so there is a conflict
between the rulle text and the form that
needs to be addressed I have talked to
the agency about this issue and they
represented that they were going to go
through an expedited revision to forms
process to amend this form as it also
relates to 19 other different rules um
so they couldn't address it with this
particular proposal but they are
planning to revise that form and have
represented to me that they are going to
delete that area agency only language
which would address the
comment um but at this time there's
still a
conflict good morning Allison radme
administrator for the administrative
rules unit at the Department of Health
and Human Services um I just quickly
want to address uh the waiver form for
BDS uh that form is actually going to be
filed today for the expedited rules uh
revisions process I did get approval
from um the program last night that all
looked well to file uh like uh attorney
record had said it does touch actually I
count recounted 18 rules
that the bureau has um and we have
removed uh agencies only as being able
to submit the form uh just because it
really does I mean cover a wide variety
of people or individuals who can submit
the form including uh staff air agencies
um parents uh anyone who the rule
applies to uh so that will be filed
today all right thank you other
questions
move to
approve okay that's that's move to
approve with the uh at the edits
understanding with the edits and that
the form will be uh corrected okay any
further
discussion those in favor I
opposed okay moving right
along I'm CH I move we uh reorder the
calendar and push Dees to the end yes
we'll do
that so we postponed the other HHS rule
fishing
game okay so um these rules are on the
interference with hunting trapping or
fishing um they basically they new rules
and they establish a Prohibition on
interfering with hunting trapping or
fishing um the statute was enacted in
198 9 and amended in
2016 but it appears that this is the
first time that the agency has moved
forward with rules um it may be that um
they didn't have reason to do so I'm not
really sure um the statute does require
that the agency adopt rules to
administer it um you do have a copy I
believe of that of the statute at the
end of your packet but anyway that's the
only issue with the rule and so you may
have some questions about the delay in
bringing the rules forward
good
morning morning good morning I'm Marty
Mobley I'm the legal coordinator for
fish and game and with me today is
Captain Michael
Eastman um apparently neither one of us
were working at the department in
1989 um so we don't really know why no
one adopted the rules at that time but
uh we do have authority in the statute
to enforce the statute and it has
recently been discovered that the the
rules were not in implemented according
to the statute we've been criminals um
since 1989 and not abiding by the
statute but uh so I set about rectifying
that situation and have adop and
proposing to adopt the rules so that
we're no longer in violation of the
law any questions
comments repr V um thank you madam chair
and thank you very much um as a land
owner that has Land open to hunting I
just want to clarify that lawful hunting
would only be those with permission of
the landowner and we wouldn't need to
exempt them in rules as well or should
we exempt a landowner if somebody is U
participating in unauthorized
hunting this would not uh exempt you
from not allowing certain persons to be
on your property at all this would speak
about harassment of hunters on open
lands okay thank you thank
you anyone
else we do
approve second by Senator
gray any further
discussion those in favor I I
opposed thank you and congratulations on
having some new
rules
all right
oplc um so this is an interim rule that
was filed by the oplc regarding license
by
endorsement um the oplc had filed uh a
conditional approval and then an amended
conditional approval um which resulted
in me just having two remaining comments
uh the first is that informational note
regarding the PLC 10002 rules which I
won't get into uh but the second com
is regarding the appendix and I want to
start by clarifying that the appendix is
normally just an editorial matter um
that is addressed um either at adoption
or during
certification um however uh in this
instance we would argue that the board
statutes that have certain statutory
requirements for licensing should have
been included in this particular
appendix uh because the statute had
required oplc to adopt these rules in
consultation with the boards on what
would be substantially similar to the
New Hampshire requirements so if there
are statutory requirements for certain
professions in New Hampshire uh anyone
who is trying to get a license by
endorsement should be aware of what
statutory Authority uh their
requirements are being compared to um so
because of that we would say that this
is technically a violation of RSA 541 A8
which requires adherence to the manual
requirements and the manual is very
clear that any statutory Authority that
is being relied on uh needs to be
reflected in the appendix and to just
further this point um I pulled an
example um from the um
mlc statutes uh RSA 330
c16 requires that M ladex have at least
a master's degree and and looking at
these rules that requirement is also in
these rules um at uh PLC
31313 and in looking at that section as
well
the statute for the definition of
um CL iCal hours or I'm sorry core hours
are is uh in that rule as well they
specifically cite that statutory
definition by referencing the statute so
that should at least be apparent in the
appendix um and that is the only comment
I had on this
proposal all
right thank you madam chair Lindsay
Corney executive director
OPC
um I I think we can resolve the issue
with the appendix but I think we
disagree age that the manual is clear um
and having reviewed the manual in
particular um chapter 3 I think it's
2.4 um regarding the cross reference
table uh directs agencies to identify
the specific provisions of state or
federal statutes or regulations that the
rules in your proposal carry out or
Implement and I would submit that what
we are implementing is a statutory
Authority granted to the oplc now
certainly that statutory Authority in
order to implement that we have to look
at other resources which would include
State statutes but which would also
include State rules which would also
include other extraneous materials um
explaining you know exactly what lure
means in our states and in other states
when we do that
analysis the office is particularly
sensitive um to any um attempt to uh
claim for the office to claim authority
of the boards that does not belong to
the office I think the committee is
particularly aware of the sensitivity
surrounding this issue um as we've seen
numerous proposals come out throughout
the years um regarding which regulatory
body should have authority to to conduct
a particular activity so um absent the
committee um asking us to include this
in the appendix we do not think we are
leg legally obligated to do so according
to 58 and the manual and also we would
prefer not to do so
um recognizing that the boards have
retained certain Authority and that uh
that Authority belongs to
them
committee yes Senator um
so you say that how would including the
the this information in the appendix in
any way detract from the authority of
the
boards so it's not necessarily a
rational position but anytime the
oplc has basically stated that we have
the authority pursuant to the
requirements granted to the board that
is not viewed uh very well by the boards
who are particularly sensitive to
retaining their Authority so I'm not
saying it's a rational um thought but
I'm saying that I think the office has
to be particularly sensitive to that as
we work to collaborate with the boards
in Partnership and we do not want to
appear to be trying to usurp their
authorities
so I mean at the end of the day if the
commit thinks we need to include it for
transparency then then we certainly will
um legally I disagree with 's uh
analysis um at least to the extent that
they're saying that the manual is clear
I do not think it's clear um but but I I
always want to weigh on the side of
being cautious and not trying to over St
the bounds of the office's Authority
versus the
agencies I also just would like to
clarify one point that was brought up by
director Courtney the manual doesn't
require that every single potential
resource that they rely on has to be in
the appendex it is only State uh
statutes and then Federal Regulations so
those are the only two that need to
apply for the
appendix okay and I can agree that
there's probably statutes and rules all
over the place that might affect these
but
um it it seems to me that someone coming
in and looking at these requirements
might want a link to where the ward
requirements are
because uh and that that's what strikes
me whether it's in statute or
rules um you want to say what we require
of our applicants and what we require of
people by endorsement so
you um that that would make sense to me
at least I think it makes sense but I
think without the committee saying that
this is what we'd like you to do I think
given the Dynamics surrounding this
transfer of authority the office is was
not inclined to do that um okay I think
they need to be transparent Madam chair
and put the information in the appendex
um like we said in the comment we could
ourselves amend that appendix it is an
editorial matter we'd much rather prefer
that they do
it okay so M chair yes so a couple
things this is also an interim Rule and
you're going to go into full-blown rule
making this is to implement legislative
changes that just were enacted that you
need to enact rules in order to enforce
correct things again like that uh the
endorsement the the substantially
different to allow out of sters to be
able to come in and practice in the
state of New Hampshire is that correct
yes and you are planning on going the
full-blown Ru making to smooth out these
differences if you will and also to
include a number of other professions
right certainly this only has a this is
only a start right
correct we're currently working on rules
right now um and which would expand the
professions that are included but
essentially what we did is we we looked
at where are we going to get the biggest
bang for our book so to speak where do
we think the current endorsement
criteria is maybe um uh too onerous and
maybe we can or conversely where do we
have work for shortages that even a
small change in the criteria um we would
see a benefit in this state so we picked
a handful of professions except like
good
yes okay anyone else um I I just also
want to make as the commit is probably
already aware but everyone aware that we
are in the process of amending our
manual because we have had a number of
statutory Updates this past legislative
session so if there's any
recommendations or anything that
agencies or boards are concerned about
certainly they're more than welcome to
submit to our office and we'll try to
include those in the changes and
additionally the manual will become come
before the committee um with those
changes for public viewing okay and
Senator Lang is absolutely right the
change to the appendix can be made
during regular ruem they don't need to
do this now okay well we will in that
case not insist on anything for the
interm rule except that I believe we
have some comments from the public Mr
ran
Cort thank you madam chair my name is
Steven rort licensed electrician in
state of New Hampshire we just had some
concerns and uh we're passing out a
um some wording we're not really sure
like with regards to our discipline what
the actual wording is going to be I
don't know if you have it in these in
rules we submitted this back in uh
beginning of September to the oplc
lawyer Gretchen and suggestions it went
in front of our board last minute at the
last meeting and they had agreed with
this changes so this inum rule process
seems to be moving along like no with no
Gap stop and and it's kind of concerning
um some place like us as far as a
profession who already reciprocates with
almost 22 States has a pretty good
guideline is very open to reciprocal we
have no issues with that we encourage
that but we don't want it so that these
rules make it harder for somebody who's
living in the state to get a license in
somebody outside the state um some
simple things it was missing the
schooling it was some reference to the
hours they had four years or 8,000 hours
but you could work parttime for four
years and not gain the 8,000 hours so
there was just clean cleaning it up and
there was some information about the
schooling that's required for us to us
the substantially equivalent would mean
for example we require 576 hours of
schooling if they had you know 550 or
something there that that would be
substantially equivalent if they had you
know 7,900 hours you know what I mean
that would be but not having it so that
they may only have a two-year program or
half the schooling or half the hours and
stuff so we would suggest and ask the
committee to accept this is the interim
rules going forward for at least PLC
1323 and uh I'm sorry um Mr Ring Court
first off can you spell your last name
for me sure it's r a n c o u r t thank
you and I just want to clarify this
handout that you provided are these the
um suggested amendments your board is
asking be incorporated or it was this
just taken from what is already in the
proposal so I don't know what you're
actually looking at for wording now cuz
again lack of communication we have no
copy it was suggested this is what we're
suggesting should be the full Waring it
had some of theirs in there and we took
from that but I don't know what you're
looking at now for from the original
rule um for the
Journeymen there's they add the WR the
new number one is
new number two is amended to delete the
years and simply concentrate on the
hours three is new and four is the same
as the as the rule and if if I may Madam
chair number one was put in there
because we have agreements with them so
it's just clarifying it that we have
reciprocal agreements with States
already that they would obviously get
the license by reciprocity without
anything else in them
okay
uh I have one question I know that Maine
has a residential only
classification that is not considered
equivalent what in this
would would invalidate that uh that
position would validate or invalidate
invalidate well typically they limited
license they kind of call it which is is
less hours half the hours half the
schooling ah okay is kind of how they
would do that it doesn't meet the the
hours of the schooling okay thank you
very much
any other questions or comments from the
committee yes some motion I guess I just
have a procedural question so um again I
I think that these type of changes
belong in a regular rul making process
and not necessarily here at ja car to
Institute new rules that haven't been
vetted by anybody you know other than
what we're hearing today so I guess my
question is have you brought these to uh
the commissioner and has she that they
seen them to be did they consider
adopting them or were they just not in
the public in whatever process they had
for the creating the in you say
commissioner you mean Lindsay the
executive director executive director um
I reached out to uh the oplc lawyer who
was dealing with the Gretchen uh had
corresponden back and forth she sent me
the information I sent back the
suggestions she said she was going to
give them to uh Lindsay and Dave Doug
and um no one ever got back to me as of
even the last yes the other day I had
checked in with her and they had no she
had no information or responses we they
presented this to the board wasn't on
the agenda last minute right before the
meeting was going to cancel to try to
get the board's approval and it didn't
go well with the board so this is
supposed to be in consultation with the
boards but the board suggested what you
see in front of you and and gave that to
the lawyer representing our board to
bring to them and again crickets so I
okay thank you thank you Mr rancor
director
Courtney uh and before the director
speaks I I just want to let the
committee know that the statute does say
that this um in order to establish
requirements that are substantially
similar the oplc does need to consult
with the board so that is in the
statute thank you I I appreciate Mr ran
Court's uh comments but I disagree with
the characterization of the process I
also want to clarify that Mr court is
not on the electricians board um and so
procedurally what happened is we prior
to initiating interm rulemaking we came
up with a draft and as the committee is
probably aware this is a this is a high
priority of the governor we were asked
to move this along um in order to make
uh make some changes in our state with
respect to Workforce and so um the
agency made this a priority and picked
certain professions again that we
thought um we could essentially create a
more streamline requirements so as soon
as we had a proposed
draft um we provided to the board
administrators Who provided it to the
boards now it's our expectation that the
boards if they view this as uh important
will take a look at this and decide to
convene a meeting if they so choose to
do so um the electricians board did have
a meeting with their regularly scheduled
meeting it was on the agenda um and they
agreed with the feedback of Mr ranc
Court um I I I am aware that our
attorney has communicated with Mr ranc
court so I I disagree that there's been
a lack of communication there um but
specifically I I can't confirm that what
we discussed in our office was
communicated to him so I apologize uh to
Mr ranor if this is uh the first time
he's hearing this but essentially with
respect to the electricians board we
pulled up the statute which is licensing
requirements and and what it says is
after June 30th the board shall issue a
license as a master attorney man
electrician to any person who files an
application and meets the following
qualifications completion of 8,000 hours
of service as an apprentice the board
may give credit towards such service for
satisfactory completion of a course of
instruction in the field or a school
recognize the board this particular
statute does not appear to require the
education that is proposed and so when
we talk about what's substantially
similar I personally do not think that
imposing an educational requirement um
is actually statutorily mandated by our
statute and so therefore we chose at
this time not to make changes to our
interim rules but I think certainly we
can go through the rulemaking process
the regular rulemaking process and
continue to confer with the
boards motion I move to approve the uh
interim rule as presented with the
comment that please work with the boards
to make sure that future rules that are
coming forward for final rule are
a little more Cooperative certainly
Senator
second second by representative Lim
representative Chandler oh so Chand um
thank
you
um I just want to you know if we do uh
approve this interim rule I just want it
noted that um although um we may not ask
for the inclusion of certain items in
the appendix at this time um for the
interim rule that should not be taken as
meaning that um we do not think that
they should be included in a final rule
agreed yeah I I agree with that
completely I think the the point about
having the reference uh being helpful to
people that are applying is important so
I I think that for the final rule it
should be in
there okay understood we will make that
change so having discussed this many
times within the Edna
committee I think it's important that
there
are many legislators who feel that
although oplc has the authority they
also need to work in cooperation with
boards so I just want to make sure that
because that's going to be something I'm
going to be looking at in the future in
rules so that has to be that has to be
evident and it has to
be um
transparent certainly representative we
would agree that if I may just comment
um we are happy to cooperate um but I
think it's very difficult and for the
most part we have very good
relationships with most of the boards
but it's uh certain boards are very
hesitant and reticent to change and are
not interested in cooperating with us
and so um our concern is that uh we
can't drag Ru making and implementation
of our statutory directives because the
boards are not coming to the table I'm
not making a representation that that's
a problem with respect to this
rulemaking but it's generally an issue
so um I also think that the expectation
should be that boards partner with the
office in order to implement the
statutory directives that the office
has okay thank you any other
comments all right those in favor I I
opposed okay thank you very much and uh
have fun with the with the full-fledged
Ru making
okay let's moving on to
Dees okay so 2023 137 um fines relating
to hazardous waste management these
rules establish fines for violation of
hazardous waste statutes and other rules
um the rules expired in 20 uh in 2008
rather and the statute does require the
agency to establish finds via
administrative rule um in order to
enforce that statute the agency stated
in its notice that it received advice
from the Attorney General's office that
it could enforce the inspir expired
rules however the agency doesn't State
whether or not they received that advice
prior to or after the amendment to
541a that explicitly prohibits the
agencies any agency from enforcement of
expired rules for any purpose um the
agency States in their response to
comments um that they have been
enforcing the rules um that they've been
continuing to do so and they've been
proposing fines under the rules using uh
using those rules as
guidelines um so clearly you know the
agency has violated
541a uh 22 um on not enforcing expired
rules and certainly the agency's actions
are not in the public interest and um
they may not be fair are transparent but
those actions don't qualify as a basis
for objection and the reason why um we
we say that is because the language in
the statute says that the committee May
object to a proposed rule if the rule is
beyond the scope of the authority
contrary to legislative intent
determined not to be in the in the
public interest it it's pretty clear it
says the proposed rulle so here what
we're talking about is past agency
action um in violation of 54 41
a22 so you know we understand this
result is a little frustrating and um we
are uh staff are looking at 541a and the
jail car rules to um recommend some
amendments to address situations like
this and we're thinking at a minimum of
requiring the agencies to provide a
report of all the enforcement actions
taken fines or fees assessed um during a
rules expiration but anyway that's the
only issue with the this proposal and um
with that I'll I'll let you ask your
questions Madam chair director I would
add to um what Kim has said in that the
notice also indicated that the
department was using two specific do
internal documents to determine whether
or not to impose a fine that means those
documents contain at least some rules
and they cannot incorporate those by
reference and they're obviously not laid
out because the rules are expired
all
right hello Pam Monroe uh appearing for
the Department of Environmental Services
I'm the legal unit
administrator my name is Carrie Barnsley
I'm a Staff attorney I work for attorney
Monroe one part of the explanation I
would like to point out um at the outset
is that um I came to the agency in 2020
and during the pandemic now Comm
commissioner Scott suspended the
imposition of of administrative fines
when um you know vaccines came out and
and things started getting back to
normal um we commenced with
administrative fin actions and when we
did that we received a motion to dismiss
um in one of the matters that was before
the hearing officer and commissioner
Scott issued a he granted that motion to
dismiss issuing an order and since that
time the department has no longer uh saw
administrative fines we have other
authorities to address uh violations of
um environmental uh compliance including
issuing administrative orders and
referring those matters to the Attorney
General's office for civil penalties but
I just want the committee to be clear
that since that time um we have not been
issuing fines we're here today we were
directed by the commissioner to fix this
issue to uh promulgate rules for for the
various statutes that do require um
admin uh rules regarding the
administrative fines these are the the
amount of the fines not all of our
statutes require that I just also want
to note that so this is the first of
other um substantive rules that you'll
see coming before you to address the
this problem um and I just wanted to
make you aware of
that thank you representative Lyn yeah
so I I just want to make sure I'm I'm
understanding so am am I you you
mentioned that this um that uh
commissioner Scott had issued this um uh
decision to suspend collecting the fines
in sometime post pandemic am I
understanding that correctly or dur
either during or post pandemic post post
pandemic we resumed um issuing we we
issue a notice of proposed fine and
hearing to the respondent you know we
have due process obviously and and they
have an opportunity for a hearing and
when we resumed that there was this
particular case that was brought forward
and the attorney for the respondant
filed a motion to dismiss on the basis
of the fact that the administrative
rules with the schedule of fines was
expired for that
okay and that that motion was granted by
commissioner Scott we were directed not
to continue that practice so what I
guess if I understand correctly the
statute that was referred to earlier
which said that
um no rules can be enforced if they're
no longer in effect that statute was
passed in 2015 if I understand correctly
and so I my guess my question is what
was happening between 2015 and 2020
um when the P when the pandemic uh
happened I'll I'll continue but feel
free to hop in um before my my time
there um but they the the department was
taking administrative actions they were
proposing fines they were in those uh
pleadings um they were putting forth the
the fines that the the rules were
expired and that we were seeking fines
and a court using them as guidance there
were decisions issued by the hearing
officer that was a design of other
Commissioners um where those fines were
imposed and um that was that was the
practice so they're used as guidance
along with our compliance Assurance
response policy I ask one please follow
just one follow-up question the the
advice that you indicated you received
from the Attorney General's office was
that was that advice received before or
after the 2015
statute good morning um Judge Lynn I was
the essentially the prosecutor of all of
the administrative fine actions the
contested
actions uh since uh I started in
2004 so I was working for the legal unit
in 2008 when these rules expired at the
time I had no role in promulgating rules
but but the unit administrator at that
time uh advised me that we could
continue to uh pursue administrative
fines under the statutory authority of
the commissioner to impose fines even
without the rules and we continue to do
so we continue to do our fine actions in
a very similar manner uh than we did
prior to the uh expiration of the rules
and in almost every contested case the
commissioner design
you know I certainly noted it in my
pleadings that the fine rules were
expired uh and in every decision that
the commissioner design made the
hearings officer made for the 12 years
that that particular one was there when
who was there in 2008 um he he noted
that he noted that that's exactly what
the uh division was doing when it
proposed the fine and he took that into
account in imposing the fine uh
on behalf of the commissioner so it was
noted in every case and I do want to add
that more than one of our administrative
fine decisions contested decisions which
represents a minority of our
administrative fines actions most of our
actions are done uh by agreement and
they have all the information we're very
transparent but as far as the contested
actions a couple a couple few have been
appealed to the Supreme Court one in
particular um was appealed in
2020 and this particular point was not
brought up this very specific issue but
the court
considered how we calculated a fine how
we proposed a fine and how that fine was
ultimately
imposed and it went through our
compliance Assurance response policy and
know went through our process in its
deliberation in this in in the order uh
and did not find fault with it so again
just for me professionally I believe
we've been doing the right thing and I
and I'm hardpressed to believe I argued
uh in the case that attorney Monroe
mentioned I argued for the division that
the motion to dismiss should be uh
should not be granted um I argued rather
vociferously because I've been doing
this for quite some time and uh I but I
really believe that the alternative
and and frankly it's the alternative
right now is for these cases to go to
the Attorney General's office and the
Civil penalties and the process is much
more challenging than the administrative
fine process which is intended to be
like a small claims process and I have
always been very transparent about the
expiration of the rules and how we
calculate fines and and how we work out
agreements the compliance Insurance
response policy essentially tells people
how I negotiate for the division and
that's online that's public that's a
public document so uh so that's how
that's how it has worked and that's the
advice that I received through my uh
administrator I don't assume to know
exactly what the Attorney General said I
don't believe their office said you can
continue to enforce these rules I
believe as it was transmitted to me it
was said is the commissioner can
continue to impose
fines um and then we just continue to
use the rules as as govern
guidelines can I ask may I ask one of
the followup so so am I understanding
from what you're saying that in addition
to the statute that has been um referred
to that say that says the um the
department shall issue regulations and
establishing a schedule of fines that
that kind of thing in my understanding
that in addition to that statute there
is another statute that just sort of
generally gives the commissioner the
authority to impose fines that is that
what you're saying or we we have many
statutes uh that authorize the
commissioner to impose fines and they're
basically subject matter oriented so for
instance the case that was dismissed was
a subsurface case a septic system case
and so that was brought under
45a
4044 I think um 40 so in that in that
statute it says the commissioner has the
authority and many statutes read
similarly the commissioner has the
authority to impose fines up to a
certain amount 2,000 in some cases it's
been raised to 4,000 some cases it's
been raised to 5,000 and then in a
separate sentence it says the
commissioner shall um adopt a schedule
of administrative fines so it it's
separate and I would argue that the
statute doesn't say if you don't adopt
the schedule which which they did years
ago uh if you don't adopt the schedule
that doesn't mean you you can't impose
the fine and that's exactly what I
argued uh in the uh objection to the
motion to dismiss a lot of our statutes
say exactly that and and and I surveyed
other statutes of other departments and
a lot of their statutes are similar we
have several statutes that don't say
that our Wetland statute and our
Shoreland statute does not speak to a
schedule of fines and our air statutes
um have it the Matrix that you would
have seen that was in our car that is in
our carp our compliance Insurance
response policy that would have been in
the expired rule 610 uh and that is at
actually similar to the one that's at
the end of this rule that's being
proposed um you know that that Matrix
has been consistent and it's in the air
a similar Matrix is in essentially in
the air statute so different statutes
have have a slightly different method
for imposing fines uh and and again it
goes primarily by subject matter and
attorney Monroe's idea has been to
instead of trying to redo the whole
block of of a dozen or more um
administrative fin schedules in in a
what's essentially a procedural rule
envc 600 um we're moving them to the
subject matter rules so now this
schedule of fines will be in the has
waste uh subject matter rules so the
idea hopefully is going forward is that
it'll be just regularly updated as they
update their rules so that that's that's
the idea of in terms of going forward
how how we resolve
this Dr moral um I agree that the
statute in question for these particular
types of fine gives the authority to the
commissioner to U impose fines but that
very same statute says the commissioner
shall adopt a schedule of fines which is
what basically you have in front of you
as a proposal um
and this is a fundamental basis for
rulemaking if you don't have authority I
mean if you don't adopt the rule then
the rule cannot be imposed and that's
what has been done at least between 15
and 20 that they were imposing fines
that they did were could not legally do
under 5418
221 Senator thank you so I guess I guess
uh and and again this is a rospective
look we're looking at in this
conversation right not necessarily
looking forward but going backwards it I
guess my question is maybe judge Lind
may have a comment on this but part of
me looks at these rules as being the um
a mandatory sentencing for lack of a
better phrase right there's a a list of
mandatory sentencing and in any other
instance if we took away mandatory
sentencing it doesn't do away with a
judge's right to still sentence and so I
guess my question here is if we took if
we took away so-called mandatory
sentencing like this does it actually
take away the agency's over the the
overriding right that's allowed above to
issue
fines and and without without the
mandatory sentencing does that
automatically strike their their
abilities at any
fine well it it would conflict with the
current statute that does require a
schedule of fines uh it can raise the
issue of how the department determines
what fine shall be imposed for a
specific violation uh the statute says
up to $2,000 but how do they decide
between $100 and
$2,000 in the proposed rules they say
for this violation the fine shall be
this
amount so the follow-up question would
be with the with the expiration of fines
I know historically are are we've had
agencies issue refunds and absent those
rules but given the over the larger
Authority um of that they're allowed to
set up to a $2,000 fine um without the
mandatory sentencing so to speak does
that mean they have to issue the
refunds good
question can
I may I I think many of those uh the
programs the administrator finds go into
the general fund just for your
information the um in this case the
statute is pretty clear that um proceeds
of administrative f finds Levy pursuant
to this paragraph shall be deposited by
the commissioner into the Hazardous
Waste cleanup fund established by one
147b for this
one and that's why we're here to correct
this today did did did I I'm not I'm I'm
not quite sure that the mandatory
sentencing analogy fits here I mean but
but the other thing is it did I
understand from one what a comment that
one of you made I'm sorry I apologize
I'm not sure which which of you said
this but that you were using even when
the rule was expired you were sort of
using the guidelines of the rule as a as
sort of a template to decide what fines
would be and it it it really does seem
to me that that supports what the
director is saying that the intent here
of the statute I mean I suppose you
could pull one line you know one
sentence out and say well that that that
gives General authority to impose fine
even if you don't have rules but that I
don't know it sort of seems to me that
that is it's an arguable interpretation
of the statute but I'm not I'm I'm not
sure that it's a good one I'd like to
comment
that two two things first did the
attorney gen General issue that guidance
in
writing not that you know of
lovely also I can see you're relying on
that guidance and your expired rules in
2008 but when we specifically changed
the law in 2015 to say that expired
rules cannot be
enforced I'm very concerned that you
decided on your own that you should
ignore that change and simply continue
working with your expired rules I I
don't I I sure hope that that was not
intentional I I worked for the
Department for many years and I would
hope that we did not in so too but
that's certainly what it looks like to
an outside person I mean we we changed
the law specifically to prevent expired
rules from being
enforced
and your department for some reason did
either didn't notice that change or
decided to ignore it and kept doing what
you had been doing is that a fair
interpretation
well I would assert that the same people
that were were directing me to do my job
in 2008 were still there in
2015 uh including the commissioner I
believe um and that was not simply not
brought up to the best of my knowledge
the intent was to starting in 2006
because I remember the email starting as
far back as 2006 the intent was to uh to
to do new rules to re adopt rules um and
they were had been worked on on and off
to my knowledge from 2006 through today
and in fact in
2014 the new 601 through
605 which you just you just uh uh agreed
to the repeal of today um was put in
place and they didn't really include a
schedule of fines but they spoke a
little bit to some of the procedures of
calculating a fine and and bringing a
fine action um and in fact those rules
that were approved in 2014 referred to
like for instance the expired 610 The
Matrix or matrices in 610 they refer to
expired rules and in fact that was one
of the things that the very clever
attorney who wrote the motion to dismiss
in my case back in 2022 which ended our
our practice um mentioned that you can't
even follow that rule because it refers
to expired rules or expired fine
schedules so you can't even follow that
rule the 603 rule that talks about how
we calculate fines and those rules were
approved in 2014 which of course I was
very frustrated to see an emotion in
2022 because I was using the rules that
I was instructed to use but I will say
that I find it based on my life
experience hard
to accept when you say we are enforcing
the rules against uh the law against the
statute because the fine schedule is
just one part of what we use to decide
which fine to
propose and like I said the majority of
our administrative fine actions are done
by consent and those almost always
include some sort of discount because
we're negotiating a settlement agreement
and when I bring a contested action on
behalf of one of the divisions in front
of the commissioner's design and I'm
using the the fine that we are proposing
that we are calculating that we've
calculated the commissioner's design uh
has almost never imposed that same fine
they almost always take into account uh
certain factors they almost always
discount it so again it's not like the
fine rule said you got to pay $1,000 and
we said listen where's our $1,000 we two
Madam chair we don't issue we don't
issue I would like to introdu Senator I
would like to interrupt this right now
uh I at this time would like to uh offer
a conditional you know an objection to
this rule they're not ready uh they we
need the department and we need our
staff to go and reach consensus and come
back to us we don't need to do all of
this you know that it's it is not ready
for us to work on and
therefore whatever staff tells me is the
right uh motion either to object or to
postpone uh I willing to make that after
they tell me which
one Senator Ling so Senator the great
thanks for the comment again I I don't
know that there's any argument about the
rule itself other than it's expired so I
think the rule is written is okay and a
motion to approve would be okay but the
question is what happens with the
retrospective aspect of all these fines
that were issued while the rule was
expired is that correct I thought that
was correct until uh attorney barnesley
just spoke in saying that there are
other considerations they take uh and
the fine amount can vary the way these
rules are written I don't see that it's
this shall be the fine there's no talk
about mitigating factors or other
considerations so again I think that if
this rule of the pass these would be the
fines and there's no mitigating factors
because it says sh be fined and so that
would be the new law of the land so to
speak well so the these these rules
would be the basis for which we would
plead the fine but we still the
respondents still have a right to a
hearing and they present evidence and
the commissioner ultimately makes that
determination but the the rules
themselves would be the basis for the F
the fine that we would
propose so if I may that's not what the
rule says because again just pick any
one of these and it says that if you're
violate you know evh
w3044 F the fine shall be $1750 per
inspection not conducted there's no
wiggle room in there for what the fine
is it says specifically this is the fine
there's no mitigation of that in in the
rules that you're
proposing well the process is to provide
for a hearing and uh the absolutely you
get your due process for yes or no it's
guilty or not guilty but you don't
necessarily get a anything other than
you know this mandatory sentencing of a
fine right this this is the this is the
fine if you violate this
law I I I don't know that the mandatory
sentencing uh analogy not let's not
confuse the issue with
that am I correct in interpreting that
these are these are hard and fast fines
once this rule is adopted they appear to
be yes uh there are often times where
with other agencies where you will
mitigating and aggravating factors or
other considerations to take into uh
account when imposing fines uh I know
HHS often has something if there is no
dispute if it doesn't go to hearing then
you're going to get an automatic 25%
reduction in the amount of f all right
does dees have such a general rule that
is you know given a a scale schedule of
fines this is how we choose to apply it
or what factors we consider when
applying it we would apply the fine in
the rule and then we have adjudicative
um procedural rules as required under
541 a30 and we would have a hearing but
the pleading would be what's in the rule
all right so so you start with the
schedule and go on from there depending
on the negotiations is that correct or
during the during the hearing process
they may produce evidence that we were
not aware
of okay well
that's I have to agree that I I was
prepared to approve the rule and argue
your process or or the history
separately but it sounds like there are
things we need to understand as to how
this rule is applied before we we try to
approve it so does anyone have a motion
can we can we uh postpone us um is there
a deadline on this October
30th so we could postpone us till next
month and take this back up and let them
submit a CA for for um you know changes
or some backup information on your
procedural rules so that we know that
this is this is not a mandatory sentence
as it appears to Senator Lang but rather
the starting point for
negotiations right man just make I mean
it it sounds
like it I completely understand what
you're saying in terms of the way you in
you know the way fines may be imposed in
any particular case it it sounds like
you are you are not interpreting these
these rules I mean even if they were in
effect you wouldn't be you wouldn't be
interpreting them as being sort of
mandatory although as it as has been
pointed out by the by the staff that
that seems to be the way they're work
word it so if you if you want to have
some for lack of a better term some
wiggle room to be able to consider you
know various factors in mitigation or
whatever then the rules should probably
say that um as opposed to Simply as
Senator Lang points out as to simply
saying if you do this this is the this
is the consequence no if Sands or butts
um yeah you you the rule ought to be the
language ought to be amended probably to
say you know if if you do this this
happens except that we can consider but
we can also consider other factors
mitigating or aggravating whatever um
which seem to me that would make sense
so I I guess I agree with Senator Lang
as in terms of what we should do now
okay I move we postpone this until next
month absolutely all
right do thank you if I can just make
one other comment I believe that in the
past we've also when there's been
mitigating Factor look to make sure that
there's a structure so that they're
implemented consistently um so I would
be looking that when you come back that
there's a consistent way to implement
those factors or refer to your other
procedures that to talk about
that so just so I'm clear
um what is it you would like us to come
back like come back what come back with
something better right so again I I
think the issue is that
staff as well as myself think that your
fine schedule is a finite is a fixed
Point not a not a moving point and
you're saying it's being implemented as
a moving point so bring rules add rules
to this that talk about why it's a
moving point what makes it a moving
point versus shall be language that's
currently in the rule if you want to do
that if that's what you're you if you
want to have that variability in the
fine based on what's
fixed what I hear you saying is you want
to you want to basically have us put the
commissioner's
discretion the commissioner has
discretion to decide which fine to
impose uh put that in rule whe whether
or not he can have discretion because I
will tell you that I argue that the fine
that the division is proposing should be
imposed but very often the
commissioner's designate the hearings
officer takes into account the entire
hearing all of the evidence all of the
record and then imposes a fine that is
not always is exactly what is in the
fine schedule even before these fines
expired so I guess my statement is that
process needs to be integrated into this
rule so
that if it's in a different rule please
point out what rule it's in what we're
concerned about is that not commissioner
Scott but some future commissioner will
say oh the fine for this is
$2,000 but this is my friend you're
talking about so we're only going to
make you pay2 200
you know if if it's entirely at the
commissioner's discretion without any
guidance then it's open to
corruption I will say the emvc 200 is
our process as then we well thank you we
would love to uh reference that as
well okay so would you like that in
writing prior to the meeting for
consideration okay we will do that
director moral one thing that could be
done is say this is the standard fine
however it is subject to change uh
pursuant to the judicative proceeding
based on factors and then they could
give two or three factors and then a
general catch all I mean the other other
case that comes up is that some naive
operator says oh finds $2,000 here okay
here's your 2,000 and somebody that's
been around for a while says oh I'm
going to appeal and and they all get
knocked down to 1,000 I mean that's a
sort of thing that can happen with this
kind of of written
rules so please the more information on
your process the
better okay we will do that okay thank
you all right is there anything
else that's the last
item so this is an objection response um
from the Department of Health and Human
Services regarding the Foster family
care licensing
requirements um there is one written
comment in the objection response
meeting packet that is posted online
however after putting that packet
together and posting and having
additional
conversations uh with the agency I do
have one additional comment um that the
agency is aware of but I will go over
that
orally um but to start just to remind
the committee
that the objection was based on three
points the first was the rule was
unclear due to the agency not being
clear of when the application is
completed in order for the agency to
issue a decision within 60 days to
comply with RSA 541
a29 looking at the response I did not
see um any reason for this uh point to
be upheld they did make a change to that
they made it clear when exactly this
considered complete and then in the rule
itself says that a decision will be
issued after either the completion of
that application within 6 days or within
60 days after receiving additional
information should it be requested so I
think that point has been taken care of
the second point that the signed
acknowledgement um in he C 644 6.06
d1a may be against the public interest
due to to the lack of protection for the
applicant's health care information when
it is disclosed to the Department's
providers the agency also addressed this
in their response they reworded the
language to state that even if this
protected health information were to be
given to uh redisclose to a contracted
um party that it would still be under
the protection of the state and federal
law the issue last time was there was a
line in it that said that should this be
disclosed it could um no longer be
protected under the federal law and in
looking in that
closer um the federal statute does State
um that if someone is going to authorize
the disclosure of their personal health
information that the disclosure is
required to
say and notify the person who is
authorizing the disclosure that the
potential for information disclosed
pursuant to the authorization to be
subject to redisclosure by the recipient
no longer may be protected by this
subpart so this subpart would be Hippa
that's that statement that's in the
certification so the department has made
it clear that this information may not
no longer be protected under Hippa which
allows the doctor to disclose the
information but the information still
will be protected under state and
federal laws as they apply so I think
that also has been taken care of so it's
the last issue um that I think still
needs to be uh addressed and that is
that um HC 6
44614 May no longer be enforcable due to
HB 48 becoming effective once it's
signed by the governor um that bill was
signed by the governor it's now now in
statute is RSA 170e
27b and in looking at the language
um I I think there is some still some
problems that may be fixable the first
comment that is the written comment on
page seven of the objection response I
think could be fixed if it's
rewarded um because as it's written now
um it says all household members who may
caregivers are required to have these
certain vaccinations should they be
caring for infants or infants or
children with uh disabilities I think
that needs to be rewarded to make it
clear that it's only adults who are
caregivers to ensure
that you know 16-year-old uh 17-year-old
who happens to be watching the child
acting as a caregiver is not required to
have these immunizations because they're
not statutorily required and they're not
required under the agency's rules rules
for other children other schoolage
children um which would be in violation
of this new law so I believe that needs
to be fixed I have had a conversation
with the
agency they agreed um that that could be
rewarded better and and that they'd be
willing to look into that more um the
second comment I have that is not
written uh in the packet um is also an
unclear comment um but based on the what
is intended it could also potentially be
a legislative intent
comment so the issue is that the way
it's
written could mean two different things
the first is
that the requirements in the rule which
is you know the immunizations be
consistent with the recommendations of
the American Academy of Pediatrics the
advisory committee on immunization
practices of the Center for Disease
Control another
organization I had originally read that
to mean that the dosage amounts the age
that these immunizations have to be
given those type of requirements those
type of recommendations is what was
intended if that was the intent then it
is fine as written because the agency
well it it could be rwind to make it
clear but the intent is fine because the
agency does have um a rule
specifically stating that this
requirement is for all children in the
state all schoolage children in the
state and therefore would not be in
violation of the statute so that would
just be a simple
rewarding however if the intent is that
the recommendations would also include
the types of
vaccinations that would be against the
legislative intent of this newly enacted
statute because the statute says that
children who are in the household
whether they are foster children or
biological children any child in the
home that is um sub who is essentially
caring for these foster children um need
to only be required to have the same
immunizations in the same manner as
every other schoolage child and if these
recommendations in the rule as written
intends to have additional vaccinations
that is a legislative intent issue um so
I had been in communication with the
agency unfortunately I didn't get an
answer of what was intended with this
particular paragraph so I can't say
whether it is simply unclear or unclear
in legislative intent I'm sure the
agency can clarify that but as I stated
if it's meant to be intended the first
way this could also just be fixed
because it um by being Rewritten
otherwise I would recommend um that the
committee look at making this a final
objection based on that legislative uh
intent
issue hello hi good morning afternoon
good morning uh Alison radme uh the
administr Ator for the administrative Ru
rules unit at the Department of Health
and Human Services um attorney reard is
uh correct in her interpretation um that
is more of a Clarity issue with respect
to the vaccinations required for the
children um it is our intent that they
only have the required vaccinations as
the same as school age children um so at
this point the department uh would
actually like to request a revised
preliminary objection uh to amend
paragraph h 2 and three to add uh adult
before household members to uh satisfy
the original unclear comment and then um
add language to clarify that no
vaccinations are required other than
what is required for school AG children
in our state thank you because I believe
that is the legislative
intent um and now that the agency has
requested a revise the committee would
vote on whether to issue that revised
objection and then the agency will have
an opportunity to fix that okay are
there any other questions before we do
that I'm sorry can I just ask question
for cloud to make sure I'm understanding
if if we add the if if in H2 and three
we add the word
adult is that does
that it somehow suggests that adults
don't have to be that that to be a
caregiver you don't have to be an adult
and and is that and is that is that what
is intended um so for these particular
set of rules one of the reasons that it
was unclear is because there's no
definition of what a caregiver is if the
there was a definition and it said only
adults then that would make it clear
that that's what's intended so I agree
that you know what is a caregiver is up
for interpretation however by adding
adult household members who are
caregivers I do not believe that it
would make it sound as though only
adults could be caregivers because it's
specifically speaking that these
immunizations are required for this
certain set of people not that these set
of people can only be no I so in other
words what I was concerned about is that
somewhere else somewhere else in this
rule it said only adults can be S
caregivers but you're saying it doesn't
say that unfortunately not and that's
why it's it's unclear yes okay okay got
representa Le um thank you madam chair
and I do want to clarify we're looking
to also make sure that the exemption um
under 141c 20- C applies to sections two
and three as
well um so if they put in adults in two
and three that makes it clear that those
immunizations are only required for
adults and not for children um and the
RSA
441 uh
c20a is specific that the exemptions are
for schoolage children and not for
adults I'm not clear about what statute
would require uh or would exempt adults
from certain immunizations because I
don't believe there's any law requiring
adults to be immunized um unless I'm
misunderstanding your question um thank
you that was the big debate over the
last few years about whether or not
there was a religious exemption for
adults currently there are no mandate
mandates for influenza vaccine for for
adults or for anybody um and so then
there's the concern about whether this
would prohibit a religious exemption for
um influenza or for anything else um and
I would want to make sure that that is
clear um I will I will follow up if
there are if we do have a statute that
specifically refers to adult um adult
medical sorry adult religious and
medical exemptions which I believe we
have and I can let the agency clarify I
believe that this rule is actually going
to be brought before the committee again
next year um because there are more U
revisions that will be done um if that's
something that the committee wants to
address with them when it comes around
again that certainly is something that
we can keep in mind and keep on our
radar however with regard
to um you know the the
objection there those three points are
kind of what we're limited to at this
point that sounds like a new Point
that's being brought up and UNT at this
time I I and director moral can correct
me but I believe objection responses
only have to address what's in the
objection so because at that time it's
outside the scope um we could certainly
make it a recommendation that that's
something they consider when they come
forward with their new rule but I I
don't believe it's something the
committee could really um address at
this
time Rich
moral excuse me that's correct uh once
you issue a preliminary objection any
response uh the committee cannot
subsequently add new items for objection
unless the objection response itself
creates a new basis for objection yes
and just as a followup I thought that
that applied to adults that's why I was
making this point not a problem and so
yeah so by adding adults it would
address that original issue whether or
not an exemption for adults once
again that may have been something that
could have been brought up originally
because it had specified all household
caregivers and that's not something we
really discussed the first time around
however if it's going to be revised to
say adults only
I'm unsure if if that would be a reason
I'm certainly I could talk to the
director about that um I I think that
right now we're making very very
significant process we'll work on the
adult part as we move forward and if I
may make um a motion to accept with all
of these changes or sorry if I can move
as suggested I would okay okay so we're
moving a revised objection so that the
agency can make these s agreed on
Corrections
and I'll second the motion is there any
discussion we have to point ah yes
representative grota you're in for
Senator
Lang um and and just so the revised
objection response I understand the
points for that but did you also want to
add on the recommendation that moving
forward for new rulem that they consider
whether adults should be exempt yes
please okay sure thank you okay any
further comments questions all right
those in favor I
opposed all right thank you very
much GL we got that straighten
out what we
did
all
right so other
business under other business you should
have in front of you three uh different
forms uh for newer members as part of
the manual we have uh a dozen plus forms
that agencies are required to use for
specific rulemaking actions uh because
of amendments to house bill I mean
because of amendments to
541a uh instituted by House Bill
358 there are needed changes for the
rules uh these three that are in front
of you need to be done approved they've
already been approved by the director of
legislative services but they need Jael
cars approval uh we're going to have
another 10 or so that will be before you
at the October Meeting House Bill 358
does take effect October 3rd but those
other forms are not need Ed before the
committee's meeting in
October
okay additionally we have uh a couple of
memorandums from boards and I'll let uh
Rebecca address those before before then
could you go if we have to approve these
could you uh give us a quick summary of
what the changes are to these
rules sure um I I can do that um so so
first one is the uh cover sheet for the
proposed inter room Rule and you'll see
there are some track changes um like uh
director moral was saying um the form
has been amended to comply with um the
the new language um from HB 358 you'll
see that number nine it says it's
requiring the submission of agency forms
uh right above that we've put in some
new language and that is not um as a
result of House Bill 358 but it is
something that we thought we would do at
this time and that says um whether the
rules um being proposed are implementing
a state statute for the first time so
that would get at the situation that we
had today with the fishing game rule and
we've added that same language on the
interim rule notice um so that form
didn't really need any amendments as a
result of HB 358 but we did at this time
go ahead and stick this new language in
there and you'll see that in number
eight and then on the um the notice for
expedited Vision to agency forms uh this
one has been amended to um in compliance
with HB
358 and um there they've got to indicate
what rule number is being impacted and
whether or not the uh the rule text
itself is being amended or read-option
with amend Amendment and so we've also
done some um some information some
explanatory explanations if you will how
to fill out this form uh so that's you
know new on the second page page there
um it kind of outlines for the agencies
how to complete that you know how how to
say whether or not the type of action
for the rule is either an amendment or a
read-option with Amendment so um that's
a quick summary of of the changes to
those three
forms okay does someone wish to make a
motion to approve these rules so move
seconded
okay any
discussion
all right those in favor I
oppos and on to the on to the letters
from the agencies yes so I'll I'll make
this very brief um the first one has to
do with the mechanical licensing board
uh during the last meeting the committee
had some questions about how the board
establishes whether a person is mental
mentally or physically competent to
practice um based on the application
questions this this was the memo that
was submitted by the board and it
essentially says that they rely on the
questions regarding the criminal uh
whether or not someone's been convicted
of any criminal
um I apologize and have a criminal
conviction that relates to physical or
mental uh component um whether or not
they've had uh discipline in other
jurisdic
based on physical or mental components
um so those seem to be really the only
set of questions that they rely on
there's nothing more in depth than that
um and then the second one is from the
real estate appraiser board um there was
a question about whether or not the
board had been collecting fees during
the time their rules were
expired um this particular memo um
explains that the rule that actually has
the fees in it um which is uh RB
36.0 one um actually did not expire um
so those that rule that established what
fees are charged didn't expire it's
simply the renewal process and they
further argue that under the statute
they have the right to collect fines for
renewals it's pretty clear that you know
a fee I should sorry I'll fine a fee fee
to be collected so that was all for
those
okay but director moral uh one other
quick thing yesterday we sent out a memo
to agencies summarizing the changes to
541a from the past session there were
four bills two of them were very minor
and very specific HB 358 was the big one
uh also HB 266
if the committee members would like a
copy of uh the memo the memo is very
long and very detailed it shows each
section of the bill and then our
comments on it but there is a onepage
summary I'm good for one page yes would
you please
send the onepage summary to the entire
committee and I'd like a copy of the the
full uh Extravaganza all right anyone
else who wish i' love the extravagance
as well I'll take the one as well please
yes
yeah as will
I the long one is an attachment to the
email and the email itself has the
summary okay that's fine we we can
ignore it once we we get
it I didn't hear
that so Madam chair do we need to make a
motion on the remaining
documents remain no the uh okay
the preliminary objection responses have
not yet been received so we're not going
to do anything with them
Madam chair are we going to cancel the
continued meeting I believe so we
haven't postponed anything to
it all right so our next meeting will be
the regular October meeting which is the
21st I think it's the 16th or
19th the 19th the 19th 19th the 19th of
October will be our next meeting thank
you all for coming
there's no objection we will
adjourn don't object
anybody no objection no
objection